Hudson Yards is a new lively
neighborhood that provides for people to
both lived or can play in a way which is
seems I role is to basically be the
orchestra maestro we have a lot of
skilled technicians and we've got
multiple buildings going on at one time
and we've got artists and engineers and
my job is to make sure to the best of my
ability that we're actually producing
music and not cacophony design is a very
important part of how we envision Hudson
Yards that very often you get up to
Nicole the hole basically a city because
we're building over the railroad tracks
or effectively building our own land so
we're building our own streets we're
building on sidewalks but in our laws as
we're going on Gardens
there was a requirement that in half of
the ground plane time to be open to the
sky
that's very unusual take any city block
is half the block a park no buildings
built to the lot line the nature of the
zoning meant that the buildings are
twice as big as you might think as
normal for a normal development because
we've got us open space but we didn't
fully appreciate as how big the
buildings are one challenge is just the
sheer magnitude of construction so that
you know it's billions of dollars of
construction underway at any given
moment secondly it requires a lot of
money there aren't really many banks
making 500 million dollar loans and
that's what we need we need a series of
them third challenge is making sure that
we really create a great sense of place
I've always wanted to do you know a big
commercial development in New York City
I don't think you can get any bigger
than this one
it's the Churchill phrase all my life
has been by the preparation for this
moment so we'll see how I pull it off
but getting here was the long haul